why do you wear this cross we asked our
Christian brethren this question we are
a family in humanity and we asked this
question with humility sincerity and
love truly wanting the best for all of
mankind not with him any hate or trying
to put somebody down
we are just sincerely trying to get
people to intellectually think why if
Jesus who we love dearly by the way is
one of the mightiest messengers ever
sent by God who was calling the people
to only worship the one Almighty Creator
not himself or his Blessed Mother Mary
but only the Creator along without any
intermediaries now back to the question
why do you wear the cross around your
neck have you really thought about it or
are you just blindly imitating and
fitting in someone might say this
represents his sacrifice and his dying
for my sins on the cross
sidenote jesus never ever told people to
worship him as a god little son of God
or that he was coming to die for
people's sins this has nothing to do
with his true message or teachings which
we'll get to in a moment
if Jesus as you say was killed just for
an example on an electric chair would
you be wearing a miniature
representation of an electric chair
around your neck or if he was hung would
it be a rope killed with the machete
worth they had guns at that time and was
killed in front of a firing squad would
you be wearing a 30 caliber Winchester
rifle or a bow and arrow around your
neck you see the cross has become a
good-luck charm an idol in and of itself
which totally goes against Jesus's true
teachings and message so by wearing the
cross and worshipping Him you are
totally doing opposite of what he told
you to do we see rappers gangsters
fashion celebrities wearing this
modern-day Idol around
while doing the most evil things the
cross at the end of the day can't help
you
only the Almighty can help you if you
turn to him alone there are some very
sincere good people who really loved
Jesus and is those people whom we want
to help educate and let them know that
this is exactly what Jesus and all the
messengers home the Creator sent warn
people against and that was against idol
worship or anything that can lead up to
it against human worship Saint worship
and any kind of creation worship they
all called people to worship the Creator
alone and not his creation at your worst
of times and the best of times to only
call on the Almighty alone without any
middlemen to stay away from black magic
spirit worship supposed Goodluck charms
and these strange and weird incantations
and superstitions to think and to not
blindly follow your ancestors and
popular cultural traditions if you
really love Jesus do what he told you to
do he only worshipped the creator and
called people away from creation worship
there's a statement that we can confirm
he said because it matches the
consistent message of all the prophets
and the messengers that the almighty
sent it's in John 17:3 it says now this
is eternal life that they may know you
referring to the Almighty Creator to the
one God the only true God and Jesus
Christ whom you have sent
that is Islam the Shahada this is the
truth submitting to the fact that there
is nothing worthy of any kind of worship
except the one creator alone and Prophet
Muhammad peace and blessings be upon him
is the last and final messenger that
would automatically include the belief
and all the messengers that came before
him including Abraham Moses and Jesus
the Messiah the Christ this is pure
monotheism I tell people that a great
place to start is in the heart you got
to be sincere and
earnestly asking the almighty alone to
guide you to that which is pleasing to
him start doing that today
you